-Jim Jam.
-Whoa.
This is -- this is
the original shirt
you gave me 24 appearances ago.
-Look at this.
-Late night show.
Yeah.
-You're a stud.
-Yeah.
-Thank you for coming back.
We always love
having you on the show,
-Thanks my Jim Jam,
-I saw a picture of you.
I follow you on the insta
and all the socials.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And you were just hanging out
in Australia looking
like a stud.
-Yeah, I had the best time.
I am so jetlagged,
by the way.
When does it end?
I got back on Sunday.
-Do you know where you are?
-Yeah, I'm with my Jim Jam.
Okay, good. Okay, good.
-Yes, absolutely.
I know exactly --
You know where I am?
Where I'm supposed to be.
-Wow.
-I'm gonna touch you.
That's where I am.
-What in the world?
I got booped on the nose.
-Yeah, you got booped.
I wanna boop you.
-You had booped me.
Alright, alright, it happens.
Okay, Good.
How are the babies?
Little baby Lucy.
Am I allowed...
Baby, yes.
-Can I show a photo of Lucy?
-Do what you gotta do.
Yeah, they're so good.
-Look at the baby.
-Yeah, she started
crawling last week.
-Oh, my gosh, Andy.
She is gorgeous.
-We were trying to teach her
how to crawl for a long time.
She's got big blue eyes.
She's so cute.
And Ben is alternately...
just trying to love her
and kill her.
-He's a little love.
Look at Ben.
-That's --
That's the day he met her.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
-That is unbelievable.
-I know. It's so cute.
Very sweet.
-I know your pals
with John Maher.
Yeah.
-And he actually played
"Grateful Dead" for Ben,
and Ben was dancing.
Do you remember that?
-Yes, I do remember that.
Being a dad at concerts, man,
I'm like --
-I got busted hard.
I went to see Harry Styles,
and it was not pretty.
-Why? You got busted how?
-Well, I was just dancing.
I didn't know what to do.
-Okay.
-I'm too old to dance.
-To dance?
-Yeah.
-You know what?
-At Harry --
it was embarrassing.
-My dancing
has also taken a hit.
I don't know what happened.
I used to be, like,
supremely confident.
I dance. I go-go danced
for the B-52s once
about 25 years ago.
For real?
I really did.
At the Universal Amphitheater.
Just free and with abandon.
And now I go to concerts
and I'm like...
Side to side.
-Side to side.
Thank you.
Off to the side.
-Yeah, that's what I did.
-It's so bad.
But did you get -- did people
video you dancing?
-It was sad.
There was a pit of like
maybe 1,000 13-year-old girls...
-I was going to say.
-...and they all had
their TikToks out.
-Oh, no.
-And I go, I'm already a meme.
I could just tell.
-Yeah.
-And I felt bad, and at one
point I go, maybe I won't dance.
Maybe I'm just going to cross
my arms and listen.
That was even worse.
-Then you look like
you're -- Harry's
in trouble.
-So the bands playing...
♪♪
-Yeah, that doesn't look good.
-It was not fun at all.
-No, no, no, no, no.
-It was terrible.
-No.
-Yeah. Andy, since
you've been on the show,
I want to talk
about BravoCon
because you've become
the biggest media mogul.
-Well.
-You're like --
You really are.
Andy -- BravoCon.
-Thank you.
-Like Oprah. You're like Oprah.
-BravoCon was amazing.
It was like "The Avengers,"
you guys.
It was unbelievable.
-Wasn't it 30,000.
-30,000 people came to New York.
-At the Javits Center.
-You crushed it.
-It was awesome.
And actually, I'm obsessed
with Oprah's Legends Ball,
so I threw Andy's Legends
Ball at BravoCon,
and we had 140 Bravolebrity
all on one stage.
It was awesome.
-And everyone went nuts
for everybody.
-Everyone went nuts.
It was the -- it was as close
as I'll ever feel to being Elvis
without Austin Butler's accent.
-Yeah.
-Watch what happens live.
I'm lucky enough.
I'm going to be your guest.
Monday?
-Monday night you're on.
-You recently did something
on the show,
by the way,
that you've never done before.
You've hosted the show
almost 15 years.
-Yes.
-And you did something,
and I just want to show
everyone this
is something that Andy
has never done before.
-Oh, no.
So let me be clear.
Don't make, distribute
or tag me in any [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Andy Cohen death reaction
videos, you freaks.
Why is this even a thing?
It's not even funny.
On a side note,
that was the first time
I've ever done that
on this show.
-Wow. you dropped the F bomb.
-I dropped it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Andy, what -- what made...
-We were live.
I was all whipped up,
by the way, for real
about this trend on TikTok
where they pranked people.
It was like a trend where
they would tell their parents
that celebrities were dead,
and all these people
were sending me videos of people
being like Andy Cohen's dead.
And I'm like, don't send me
these videos, and cut two,
this prank ain't funny.
-Yeah, it's not funny.
I agree with you.
-Yes. Anyway, yeah.
I was all hopped up
and I dropped the F-bomb.
And I hate it when people drop
the F-bomb on on my show
because our censor, who I've
never met, is overly aggressive
and they bleed out
like two sentences at a time.
Well, I promise you,
on Monday,
I will not say one dirty word.
-Thank you.
-I promise.
-I know you don't swear.
You're a clean team.
-I'm a gentleman.
That's why I like you.
-Boop, I got booped.
-You got booped again.
-I got booped again.
Congratulations on season 20.
My man, Andy Cohen.
"Watch What Happens Live."
Can I boop you?
-Boop.
Airs every Sunday
through Thursday --
boop --
On Bravo.
We'll be right back
with a performance
from the National.
Stick around.